I think we all have people in our lives who we love, but there's no talking to them. They have their way of seeing things or doing things, and it's hard to take. And no matter how you try to talk it out, it goes nowhere. It doesn't get solved, even if they also want things to change.
我想我们每个人的生命中都有那么一些人，我们深爱着他们，但却无法与他们沟通。他们有自己看待事物或做事的方式，让人难以接受。无论你如何尝试沟通，都无济于事。即使他们也想改变现状，问题也无法得到解决。
We're devoting our entire show today to a story like that from Zach Mack, who's a reporter. And the story is about him and his dad and how they both wanted to mend a rift that had grown between them that had lasted for years, but they couldn't figure out how until Zach's dad offered a very surprising way out.
我们今天的整期节目将专门讲述这样一个故事，讲述者是记者扎克·麦克。故事关于他和他的父亲，关于他们如何想要弥合多年来在彼此之间产生的隔阂，但却一直找不到方法，直到扎克的父亲提供了一个非常令人惊讶的解决方案。
That's going to be our whole show today-- his dad's unusual solution and how it played out. That's all I'm going to say for now. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And with that, I turn things over to Zach.
这就是我们今天整期节目的内容——他父亲不同寻常的解决方案，以及事情是如何发展的。目前我只能透露这些。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。接下来，我把时间交给扎克。
This all started about a year ago. My father called and left me this message.
这一切大约始于一年前。我父亲打来电话，给我留下了这条口信。
Hey, Zach. Dad again. Good conversation last week-- last night. Hey, I didn't remember to tell you this because I was kind of tired. But they're going to shut us down again. And it's going to be a worse shutdown than 2020 because of this EMP, that all the supply lines are going to be disrupted.
嘿，扎克。又是爸爸。上周——昨晚我们谈得很愉快。嘿，我当时忘了告诉你这个，因为我有点累了。但他们又要关闭我们了。而且因为电磁脉冲（EMP）的原因，这次关闭会比2020年更严重，所有的供应线都将被切断。
So you really want to store up two months' worth of food and water because they probably won't be able to pump water throughout the city, because that's all controlled by computers and electronics. And the EMP is going to shut down everything electronic.
所以你真的要储备两个月的食物和水，因为他们可能无法通过城市供水，因为那都是由计算机和电子设备控制的。而电磁脉冲会关闭所有的电子设备。
My dad's talking about something called an ElectroMagnetic Pulse, EMP for short, which I only know about because it's what George Clooney uses in the movie Ocean's Eleven to pull off the casino heist.
我父亲谈论的是一种叫做电磁脉冲的东西，简称EMP，我之所以知道它，是因为乔治·克鲁尼在电影《十一罗汉》中就是用它来实施赌场抢劫的。
What's a pinch?
什么是“脉冲”（pinch）？
A pinch is a device which creates like a cardiac arrest for any broadband electrical circuitry-- an electromagnetic pulse which shuts down any power source within its blast radius.
“脉冲”是一种装置，它会像心脏骤停一样作用于任何宽带电路——一种电磁脉冲，会使其爆炸半径内的任何电源关闭。
You should buy enough water.
你应该买足够的水。
I can't remember a single other time Dad left me a message expressing a safety concern, but he was really convinced this was going to happen. At one point, he even did a little math for how much water I would need to survive.
我不记得爸爸还有哪次给我留言表达过安全担忧，但他真的确信这将会发生。有一次，他甚至还稍微计算了一下我为了生存需要多少水。
So I would buy 60 times 10, which is 600 ounces. I know. I know it sounds like conspiracy theory, but they're going to do this. This is what they're planning. And I just want to have you be prepared. OK?
所以我打算买60乘以10，也就是600盎司。我知道。我知道这听起来像阴谋论，但他们真的会这么做。这就是他们的计划。我只是希望你做好准备。好吗？
OK, so just a little background-- I wouldn't describe my father as a paranoid person. I wouldn't even call him an anxious person. He's actually an optimist and usually prefers to keep things light, so a lot of dad jokes.
好了，简单说一下背景——我不会把我的父亲描述为一个偏执的人。我甚至不会称他为一个焦虑的人。他实际上是个乐观主义者，通常喜欢把事情往轻松了看，所以他会讲很多“老爸笑话”。
What else? He's held down the same job forever. He has friends-- not close ones, but there's dudes he goes skiing and sailing with. When I was growing up, Dad was kind of in his own world. Mom was always the more involved parent, the one who knew all my friends and whatever was going on with me.
还有什么？他一直做着同一份工作。他有朋友——虽然不是那种亲密的朋友，但他确实有一些一起滑雪和航海的哥们儿。我成长过程中，爸爸一直生活在他自己的世界里。妈妈总是那个参与度更高的家长，那个了解我所有朋友以及我生活近况的人。
Dad and I have never been particularly close. Typically, when I hear from him on the phone, it's during an Ohio State football game. We both love the Buckeyes, so during a game, he'll call me, like, five or six times, but not much beyond games, though. Ohio State football is the one thing we can agree on.
爸爸和我从来都不怎么亲近。通常，当我在电话里听到他的声音时，都是在俄亥俄州立大学的橄榄球比赛期间。我们俩都喜欢“七叶树”队（Buckeyes），所以比赛期间，他会给我打五六次电话，但除此之外就没多少交流了。俄亥俄州立大学的橄榄球是我们唯一能达成共识的事情。
The thing we can't seem to agree on is reality. Like so many people, Dad's gotten swept up in conspiracies. Lately, he's been talking about chemtrails, that the government can control the weather, that January 6 was staged by what he calls the "deep state."
我们似乎无法达成共识的是现实。和许多人一样，爸爸陷入了阴谋论。最近，他一直在谈论飞机云（chemtrails）、政府可以控制天气、1月6日的事件是由他所称的“深层政府”（deep state）策划的。
As he's gotten more extreme in the last few years, I've seen my mom and sister retract and shut down around him. I'm typically the one who challenges Dad on this stuff. Because I'm a reporter, I can't resist taking the bait.
随着过去几年他变得越来越极端，我看到妈妈和妹妹在他面前退缩并封闭自己。我通常是那个就这些事情挑战爸爸的人。因为我是个记者，我无法抗拒诱惑。
It's called denying us freedom of speech.
这叫剥夺我们的言论自由。
No, no.
不，不。
It's called denying us freedom of speech.
这叫剥夺我们的言论自由。
It's misinformation.
这是错误信息。
No. Who gets the right to label it misinformation?
不。谁有权给它贴上错误信息的标签？
Of course, it never goes anywhere, until a year ago. After a family blowout over the holidays that was so bad, my sister and I left early, I decided to confront my father. I could see how his beliefs were starting to strain the family, and I worried that pretty soon, there may be no coming back for him. I told him I thought he was being radicalized online and pleaded with him to hear me.
当然，这一切从未有结果，直到一年前。在假期里发生了一次严重的家庭冲突，导致我和妹妹提前离开后，我决定与父亲对质。我能看出他的信仰开始让家庭关系变得紧张，我担心很快他就会无法回头。我告诉他，我认为他在网上被激进化了，并恳求他听听我的话。
As always, he didn't agree. But what he did next surprised me. Dad texted me a photo of a sheet of paper where, in his barely legible cursive, he had written out a list of 10 predictions, 10 things that he was positive would all take place sometime in 2024, assuring me that when all of these things happened, I would see once and for all that he was right. At the bottom of the page was a challenge to a bet for $10,000.
和往常一样，他不同意。但他接下来的举动让我大吃一惊。爸爸给我发来了一张纸的照片，上面用他那几乎难以辨认的草书写下了10个预测，10件他确信会在2024年某个时候发生的事情，并向我保证，当所有这些事情发生时，我就会彻底明白他是对的。页面底部是一个1万美元的赌约挑战。
And let me just say, Dad and I are not big gamblers, nor are we rich. 10k is easily more money than either of us has ever wagered. Looking over the list, I was a combination of surprised, horrified, and also, it was a little hard to take seriously. I immediately called him up to discuss the terms of the bet.
我得说，爸爸和我不是大赌徒，我们也不富裕。1万对我们任何一个人来说，都远远超过了我们以往下注的金额。看着这份清单，我感到既惊讶又恐惧，同时，这也有点让人难以当真。我立刻打电话给他，讨论赌约的条款。
Do you have the list in front of you? Because you--
你面前有那份清单吗？因为你——
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
Can you walk me through the 1 through 10? I just want to add-- each one, I'll probably have a couple clarifying questions.
你能带我过一遍1到10条吗？我只想补充——每一条，我可能都会有几个澄清性问题。
Yeah, absolutely.
好，没问题。
Keep in mind, this call took place back in January 2024.
请记住，这次通话发生在2024年1月。
Number one, Obama will be found guilty of treason in 2024.
第一条，奥巴马将在2024年被判叛国罪。
So, like, by a court?
所以，是由法院判决吗？
Yes.
是的。
OK. Not the court of public opinion?
好的。不是公众舆论的法庭？
Correct.
没错。
OK. And then number two?
好的。那第二条呢？
Oh, yeah. Biden will be found guilty of treason in 2024.
哦，是的。拜登将在2024年被判叛国罪。
Just treason for something specific?
仅仅是因为叛国罪而针对某件具体的事？
For selling all those secrets that he had in the back of his Corvette.
因为他卖掉了他克尔维特跑车后备箱里的那些机密文件。
I don't know if that's a joke. I'm not sure.
我不知道这是不是个玩笑。我不确定。
It's partially a joke, but it's also real. I mean, it could be--
这是一半玩笑，但也是事实。我的意思是，这可能是——
It went on like this, all political. Dad's other predictions were that Nancy Pelosi would also be convicted of treason. Same for Bill and Hillary Clinton, who would go down for murder as well. That Trump would be reinstated without an election and cleared of all charges. That Biden would be removed from office. Same for both the governor and mayor of New York. And as a New York City resident, I didn't hate that last one.
事情就这样继续着，全都是政治话题。爸爸的其他预测是，南希·佩洛西也会被判叛国罪。比尔·克林顿和希拉里也是一样，他们还会因为谋杀罪名倒台。特朗普将不经选举直接复职，且洗清所有指控。拜登将被免职。纽约州的州长和市长也一样。作为一名纽约居民，我不讨厌最后那一条。
That one, I'm actually kind of hopeful we get that one because I don't really love Eric Adams. He's kind of an idiot. So I'm with you on that one. [CHUCKLES]
那一条，我其实挺希望实现的，因为我不太喜欢埃里克·亚当斯。他简直是个白痴。所以在这点上我站在你这边。[笑]
Yep, he's a total idiot. And I'm impressed that you see that. So, good.
没错，他是个彻底的白痴。我很高兴你能看出来。所以，很好。
[CHUCKLES]
[笑]
One we can both cheer for.
这是我们唯一能一起欢呼的一件事。
Eventually, we landed on his final prediction for 2024, his boldest one.
最终，我们谈到了他对2024年的最后一个预测，也是他最大胆的一个。
Number 10-- I threw this in because I thought you'd be excited about it.
第10条——我加上这一条是因为我觉得你会对此感到兴奋。
Yeah, it's an exciting one. It's probably the most exciting one.
是的，这是一个令人兴奋的预测。这可能是最令人兴奋的一个。
The US will come under martial law in 2024 because of mass rioting and chaos. So the military will have to step in.
美国将在2024年进入戒严状态，因为大规模暴乱和混乱。所以军队将不得不介入。
For the record, I was never actually excited about the possibility of this happening.
平心而论，我从未对这种事情发生的可能性感到兴奋。
Do you think this will be happening all over the country, only in certain parts?
你认为这会发生在全国各地，还是仅在某些地区？
Well, the whole United States will come under martial law. And the biggest cities will be targeted-- New York, unfortunately, Washington DC, the Bay Area.
嗯，整个美国都将进入戒严状态。最大的城市将成为目标——不幸的是，包括纽约、华盛顿特区和湾区。
OK. You seem pretty confident about that.
好的。你对此似乎相当自信。
I am 100% confident.
我100%确信。
Because this is a pretty huge shake-up.
因为这可是相当大的动荡。
Yeah.
是啊。
I would say, our country hasn't seen anything like this since the Civil War, probably.
我会说，自内战以来，我们的国家可能还没见过这种场面。
Well, not even in the Civil War. This is going to be the biggest shake-up to ever hit the United States of America and the world at large.
嗯，内战时期都没有过。这将是美国乃至整个世界有史以来最大的动荡。
I mean, I think the way you've laid it out here, there'll be a pretty clear case of, like, who's right and who's wrong.
我的意思是，我认为按照你在这里列出的方式，谁对谁错将会有一个非常清晰的判断。
Yeah. Yeah. I think it will be very black and white.
是的。是的。我认为这将是非常黑白分明的。
And if you are wrong--
如果错了呢——
Then you're $10,000 richer.
那你就能多赚1万美元。
[CHUCKLES] Yeah, but look, this isn't just about the money, right? I would like to make some positive strides for our family.
[笑] 是啊，但你看，这不仅仅是为了钱，对吧？我希望能为我们的家庭取得一些积极的进展。
Well, I think that once you see that I haven't been duped by AI and social media and the algorithms, I think you will gain a lot more respect for who I am and how I think and how I've come to believe. The other thing I want to have you say after each one of these--
嗯，我想一旦你看到我并没有被人工智能、社交媒体和算法愚弄，我相信你会对我这个人，以及我的思维方式和我所秉持的信仰产生更多的尊重。另一件事我也想让你在每一条预测之后说——
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
--too, is that, wow, Dad, you were right, and I was wrong.
——那就是，哇，爸爸，你是对的，我错了。
Same goes for you then.
那对你也一样。
OK. Absolutely.
好。完全没问题。
All right. Deal. Happy to do it.
好了。成交。我很乐意。
All right.
好的。
And so our strange bet was on. I saw Dad's challenge as an opening. Instead of just arguing until the end of time, we were actually going to settle this. And now we had a deadline-- New Year's 2025. The moment I saw his proposal, I knew I had him beat.
于是我们奇怪的赌约就这样开始了。我把爸爸的挑战视为一个契机。与其争论到天荒地老，我们实际上可以把这事解决了。现在我们有了截止日期——2025年元旦。当我看到他的提议时，我知道我赢定了。
And for the very first time, he'd have to admit he was wrong. All I had to do was wait 12 months, and once he decisively lost, I figured he'd be more open to my version of the truth, and maybe I could pull him back to reality a bit. And the timing for the bet couldn't be better because his beliefs were starting to tear our family apart.
而且这是他第一次不得不承认他错了。我所要做的只是等待12个月，一旦他彻底输了，我想他会对我所认知的真理更加开放，也许我可以把他拉回现实一点点。而且这个赌约的时机再好不过了，因为他的信仰已经开始撕裂我们的家庭。
Coming up, Zach calls his mom, who has some news of her own. Stay with us.
接下来，扎克给妈妈打了电话，妈妈也有一些自己的消息要分享。请留步。
This American Life. Zach Mack picks up his story about his year-long bet with his dad.
《美国生活》。扎克·麦克继续讲述他与父亲长达一年的赌约。
Not long after making the bet, I called my mom. My parents have been married for 40 years. They met in their 20s in Chicago, fell in love, and moved to California, where they eventually had my sister and I. We grew up in the San Francisco Bay area, a pretty liberal place, which worked for my mom because she's a pretty liberal Jewish woman.
下注后不久，我给妈妈打了电话。我父母结婚40年了。他们20多岁时在芝加哥相识，相爱，然后搬到了加利福尼亚，在那里生下了我和妹妹。我们在旧金山湾区长大，那是个相当自由派的地方，这很适合我妈妈，因为她是一位相当自由派的犹太女性。
Dad has always been the odd man out, the lone Christian conservative, though growing up he was much quieter about his beliefs. And when my parents met, neither of them were religious. But Dad got back into it when I was young. Now he's very into it. That's been difficult for my parents for decades. But now, with the conspiracy stuff emerging, it's been really hard on my mom.
爸爸一直是个异类，是唯一的保守派基督徒，尽管在成长过程中，他对自己的信仰要低调得多。我父母刚认识时，两人都不是教徒。但我小的时候，爸爸又开始信教了。现在他沉迷其中。几十年来，这对我的父母来说一直很困难。但现在，随着那些阴谋论的出现，这对妈妈来说变得非常艰难。
It's getting pretty crazy, and I don't even know half of it. We have two generators in the house. There are now eight flats of water in the garage that he bought at Costco and some kind of fancy water filter system that was a couple hundred dollars. He's stockpiling weird food.
情况变得越来越疯狂，我都不知道其中的一半内容。我们在家里放了两个发电机。车库里现在有八箱水，是他从Costco买的，还有一套价值几百美元的高级净水系统。他囤积了一些奇怪的食物。
What kind of food?
什么样的食物？
12 cans of canned chicken.
12罐罐头鸡肉。
[CHUCKLES] OK.
[笑] 好吧。
And I'm like, I have never eaten canned chicken. You have never eaten canned chicken. Why is there canned chicken? I feel like returning it all this week while he's not home. And he moved some money without my permission.
我说，我从来没吃过罐头鸡肉。你也从来没吃过罐头鸡肉。为什么会有罐头鸡肉？我觉得这周趁他不在家，我想把这一切都退了。而且他在没经过我允许的情况下动了钱。
How did he do that? He didn't need your sign-off?
他是怎么做到的？他不需要你的签字吗？
No, because it's a joint account. And he withdrew money from a joint account without telling me and made a purchase he knew I would never approve.
不需要，因为那是联名账户。他没告诉我，直接从联名账户里取了钱，并且进行了一笔他明知我永远不会批准的消费。
What was it?
买了什么？
He bought a precious metal.
他买了贵金属。
Because Dad's worried the banks are going to collapse, he wants to move big chunks of their money into things like platinum and silver.
因为爸爸担心银行会崩溃，他想把他们的一大笔钱转移到铂金和白银之类的东西上。
Why is he so unwilling to listen to everyone around him?
为什么他这么不愿意听取周围人的意见？
I don't know. I wish I knew because then I could crack it. I don't know how to pull him back. I have been very clear that I'm not sure how much more I can take. And--
我不知道。我希望我知道，那样我就能破解它。我不知道该如何把他拉回来。我已经非常明确地表示过，我不确定我还能承受多少。而且——
Have you been clear with him about that?
你明确地跟他表达过这一点吗？
Yeah, and I've even said, I'm considering leaving, ending the marriage.
是啊，我甚至说过，我正在考虑离开，结束这段婚姻。
You said that to him?
你对他这么说了？
Yeah. Which is very hard for me to say, because I'm 69. I'm about to retire.
对。这对我说非常难，因为我已经69岁了。我就要退休了。
Yeah.
是的。
Not necessarily the life I had planned for myself, to be alone. But what kind of life do I have now?
这不一定是我为自己规划的生活，要孤身一人。但现在的我还有什么生活可言呢？
Mom was initially irritated by the bet because Dad didn't run it by her first, which happens a lot, but the idea of a deadline, that was starting to make sense to her.
妈妈起初对这个赌约很生气，因为爸爸没先和她商量，这种事经常发生，但设立截止日期的主意开始让她觉得有道理。
I need an endpoint. And so the endpoint is December 31. When January 1 comes around, things have to change. I'm only going to put up-- I can barely put up with it now, and I can't put up with it after that.
我需要一个终点。所以终点就是12月31日。当1月1日到来时，事情必须改变。我只能忍受——我现在都已经快到极限了，在那之后我真的无法再忍受了。
Later, I called my sister Kira about the bet. Unfortunately, she's been having her own conflict with Dad, also about his beliefs. Two years ago, Kira came out to him. My mom and I had known for years, but Kira was always afraid to tell Dad because she thought he'd disapprove. It didn't go well. He said he'd always love my sister, but he thought she was choosing to be gay, and he didn't agree with that choice.
后来，我给妹妹基拉打了电话，告诉她这个赌约。不幸的是，她和爸爸也有自己的冲突，同样是关于他的信仰。两年前，基拉向他“出柜”了。妈妈和我知道这件事已经很多年了，但基拉一直不敢告诉爸爸，因为她认为他不会赞同。结果并不好。他说他会永远爱我妹妹，但他认为她是“选择”成为同性恋的，他不认同这个选择。
I think the hardest part is that he looked at me and told me that I was wrong about myself, and that he was right. And I don't understand how he could know that.
我想最难受的部分是，他看着我说我对自己认知的方向是错的，而他是对的。我不明白他是怎么能确定的。
Kira and I are close. And when I told her about the bet, she liked the idea of forcing Dad to confront the reality that some of his beliefs are likely wrong. But we weren't sure if that helped her situation either way.
基拉和我关系很近。当我告诉她这个赌约时，她喜欢强迫爸爸面对他的一些信念可能是错误的事实这个想法。但我们不确定这是否对她的处境有任何帮助。
So, like, let's say these things don't come true, and he's willing to say, like, I was wrong about these things, I don't feel like that would affect his beliefs around me. Like even if he's right about everything else, I'm probably still going to be gay after that.
所以，假设这些事情没有实现，如果他愿意说，“我在这件事上错了”，我觉得这也不会影响他对我的信仰。即使他在其他所有事情上都是对的，在那之后我可能还是同性恋。
So Dad and I had a year. January came and went, and neither of us put any points on the board with the bet. Then in February, Dad caught a small break with Mayor Adams. He had been under investigation for months, and things were heating up. The FBI raided one of his advisors, and someone else pled guilty to conspiracy charges. It seemed like Dad could actually win that one.
就这样，爸爸和我赌约进行了一年。1月过去了，我们俩在赌约上谁也没得分。接着在2月，爸爸在亚当斯市长的问题上取得了一点小“进展”。市长已经被调查了几个月，情况正在升温。联邦调查局突击搜查了他的其中一名顾问，另一个人承认了串谋指控。看起来爸爸在这一点上真的能赢。
Then in March, the New York governor sent the National Guard into the subway, which, if you squint, could look like the pretense to martial law. While we waited for the other predictions to come true or not, I tried to make the most of the time.
然后在3月，纽约州州长派遣国民警卫队进入地铁，如果眯起眼睛看，这看起来可能像是戒严的伪装。在我们等待其他预测是否成真的过程中，我尽量利用好这段时间。
I found myself thinking back to something Dad said to me at the end of an argument once a few years back. He said, well, you don't really know me. And I wondered if he might be right, that maybe I didn't really know him. And if I had any hope of changing his mind or even nudging the trajectory of his beliefs, I would need to understand my father better.
我发现自己回想起几年前争吵结束时爸爸对我说的某句话。他说，嗯，你并不真正了解我。我想知道他是否可能是对的，也许我确实不了解他。如果我还有任何希望改变他的想法，或者哪怕只是稍微推动一下他信仰的轨迹，我都必须更了解我的父亲。
So I decided to make a project of it. One question I still had was how he'd even gotten here, though, looking back, there were signs. I remember my mom telling me about how when I was a child, Dad didn't want me to get vaccinated. Mom wasn't having it, so I ended up getting all my shots. But I never really understood where Dad's hangups came from. But now that we had some time to kill, I could ask him.
所以我决定把它作为一个项目。我仍然有的一个问题是，他到底是怎么变成这样的，尽管回顾过去，确实有迹象。我记得妈妈告诉过我，当我还是个孩子时，爸爸不想让我接种疫苗。妈妈不答应，所以我最终还是打了所有的疫苗。但我从未真正理解爸爸的顾虑从何而来。但既然现在我们有一些时间可以消磨，我可以问问他。
I know, throughout my lifetime, you have been distrusting of vaccines. Is that fair to say?
我知道，在我整个生命中，你一直对疫苗持怀疑态度。这样说准确吗？
Yeah. Yeah, that's definitely true.
是啊。是的，这绝对是真的。
I'm wondering when that began.
我想知道这是从什么时候开始的。
Well, the seed was planted, actually, before I went to school.
嗯，种子其实在我上学之前就种下了。
As a child?
在你小时候？
As a child.
是的，小时候。
Back in the '60s, Dad was about to enter elementary school in Ohio, and there was a new law requiring vaccines.
回到60年代，爸爸正准备在俄亥俄州上小学，当时有一项新法律规定必须接种疫苗。
Now, remember, Grandpa, my dad, was a chiropractor. And so he believed in natural immunity and the body's ability to heal itself. And so he was an anti-vaxxer.
现在记住，我的祖父，也就是我的父亲，是一名脊椎按摩师。所以他相信自然免疫和身体自我疗愈的能力。因此，他是一个反疫苗者。
OK.
好的。
And I mean, we didn't call him that back then, but it's the same difference. And I just wanted to go to school, and I kept telling my dad and my mom, hey, it's OK, you know? I'm not afraid of the vaccination. I'm willing to go. And I just want to go to school. So I was not able to go to kindergarten because we couldn't find a school that would accept me without a vaccination.
我的意思是，我们那时不叫他这个词，但意思是一样的。我只是想去上学，我一直告诉爸爸妈妈，嘿，没关系的，你知道吗？我不害怕接种疫苗。我愿意去打。我只是想去上学。所以我没能上幼儿园，因为我们找不到一所不要求接种疫苗就收我的学校。
Oh, wow. So you didn't go to kindergarten?
哦，天哪。所以你没上过幼儿园？
I did not go to kindergarten.
我没有上幼儿园。
Well, do you think your dad was-- I don't know. How would you describe him? Would you describe him as stubborn?
嗯，你觉得你父亲是——我不知道。你会怎么形容他？你会形容他固执吗？
Oh, yeah. Stubborn, very opinionated, hard-headed at times.
哦，是的。固执，非常有主见，有时很顽固。
Dad was one of six children. The family was supported primarily by my grandpa, who had a small chiropractic business. That is, until the Ohio State Medical Board cracked down on him.
爸爸有六个兄弟姐妹。家里的收入主要靠我的祖父，他经营着一家小小的脊椎按摩诊所。直到俄亥俄州医疗委员会对他进行了严厉打击。
And so they literally threw my dad in jail for a couple of days--
所以他们真的把我父亲关进了监狱几天——
Wow.
哇。
--for practicing without a license.
——因为他无证执业。
The way Dad tells it, after my grandfather's business dissolved, he was never able to recover. He became so depressed that he literally couldn't get out of bed for, like, six months. And he was never the same man. That literally broke him.
照爸爸的说法，我祖父的生意破产后，他就再也没能恢复过来。他变得非常抑郁，以至于有六个月时间几乎连床都下不来。而且他再也不是原来的那个人了。这真的摧毁了他。
Wow. And how old were you when this happened?
哇。这事发生时你多大？
I was, like, 13 or 14 years old.
我大概13或14岁。
One of the things I remember most about my grandfather is how tall and thin he was, and how, one time when he came to visit us, his body had just completely changed. He had suddenly gained over 100 pounds in a very short amount of time. He was going through some mental health issues that the family never fully understood, and it was affecting his weight and his ability to sleep.
关于我祖父，我印象最深的一件事是他有多高多瘦，还有一次他来看我们时，他的身体已经完全变了样。他在很短时间内突然重了100多磅。他当时正经历一些家庭从未完全理解的心理健康问题，这影响了他的体重和睡眠。
He wouldn't really sleep during the night, which meant that throughout the day, he would constantly fall asleep. He'd be in the middle of a conversation sometimes, or even at dinner, and he'd just start snoring. Minutes later, he'd abruptly wake up and carry on as if nothing happened.
他晚上睡不着觉，这意味着白天他会不断地睡着。有时在谈话中，甚至在吃晚饭时，他就会开始打呼噜。几分钟后，他又会突然醒来，若无其事地继续对话。
This also began to happen while he was driving. My grandpa got into a number of car accidents. He totaled several cars and nearly killed my grandmother. He refused to stop driving and even went to a neighboring state to get a driver's license after his was taken away. He refused to admit anything was wrong.
这在他开车时也开始发生了。我祖父发生过好几次车祸。他报废了几辆车，差点害死我祖母。他拒绝停止开车，甚至在驾照被吊销后跑到邻州去考驾照。他拒绝承认有任何问题。
The family tried to talk to him. So did my father several times. And when that didn't work-- and I'd never heard this part of the story before-- Dad tried something else.
家里人试图劝他。我父亲也试过几次。当这些都不管用时——我以前从没听过故事的这一部分——爸爸试了别的方法。
I wrote him a long letter. I wrote him, like, a two or three-page letter and mailed it to him, because I wanted him to be able to read the whole letter so I could finish what I really wanted to say to him without interruption.
我给他写了一封长信。我给他写了一封两三页长的信并寄给了他，因为我想让他能读完整封信，这样我就可以在不被打断的情况下说完我想说的话。
And I said, Dad, I love you. I want the best for you. I'm not trying to say anything horrible or damaging or critical about you, but your whole family is concerned about you. Can't you see this? Can't you recognize that we all would like to see you live to a ripe old age? Because, I said, if you continue on this path, I don't know when you're going to die, but I know you're going to die. So.
我说，爸爸，我爱你。我想要你过得最好。我不是想说关于你的什么可怕、恶毒或批评的话，但你的全家人都很关心你。你难道看不出来吗？你难道不能认识到我们大家都希望看到你长寿吗？因为，我说，如果你继续走这条路，我不知道你什么时候会死，但我知道你会死的。所以。
Not long after this-- I was 10 years old at the time-- my parents called my sister and me into the kitchen to tell us something. But before they said anything, I already knew. My grandfather was dead. His vehicle veered off the road and flipped over.
这之后不久——我当时10岁——父母把我和妹妹叫进厨房告诉我们一些事。但在他们开口之前，我已经知道了。我祖父去世了。他的车冲出了路面并翻了车。
When I think about my grandfather, I think about how what caused his death may have been stubbornness, a refusal to listen to those around him. He was 68 years old, the same age my father was when he proposed our bet.
当我想到我祖父时，我会想到是什么导致了他的死亡：那可能是固执，拒绝听取周围人的建议。他当时68岁，和我父亲提出赌约时的年纪一样。
As the year pressed on, we continued discussing Dad's life and the things he'd come to believe. Turns out, a lot of his predictions were coming from a single source online. And something you should know about my father is that he really struggles with technology. He can barely navigate the internet. He can't even figure out how to access his own email account from his laptop.
随着这一年过去，我们继续讨论爸爸的生活以及他所相信的事物。事实证明，他的许多预测都来自网上的同一个来源。你应该知道关于我父亲的一点是，他在科技方面真的很吃力。他几乎无法操作互联网。他甚至弄不明白如何从笔记本电脑上登录自己的电子邮箱。
Around 2019, Dad got an iPad, and that felt like a turning point. It wasn't long until he started saying weird things. One time, I was home visiting, and we got into it because he was trying to tell me that the government was controlling Facebook from the very beginning, and that Mark Zuckerberg was just a pawn. And when the pandemic hit, it felt like the perfect storm. Like so many of us, Dad went searching for answers.
大约2019年，爸爸有了iPad，那感觉像是一个转折点。没过多久，他就开始说一些奇怪的事情了。有一次，我回家探亲，我们吵了一架，因为他试图告诉我，政府从一开始就控制着Facebook，马克·扎克伯格只是一个棋子。当大流行来临时，感觉就像是一场完美的风暴。像我们许多人一样，爸爸开始寻找答案。
I was googling around trying to find someone who I thought was reputable, reliable, and truly plugged into God. I was trying to find someone who was a legitimate prophet, because there's a lot of false prophets out there.
我当时在谷歌上到处搜寻，试图找到一个我认为可靠、稳妥且真正与上帝连接的人。我试图找到一个真正的先知，因为外面有很多假先知。
What Dad found was a lot of conspiracies, of course, but also the next evolution of his faith. During the pandemic, Dad came to believe strongly in prophecy, the idea that God still speaks through intermediaries.
爸爸找到的当然有很多阴谋论，但也找到了他信仰的下一个演变。在大流行期间，爸爸坚信预言，即上帝仍然通过中间人说话。
When you're talking about how God speaks today and you believe it's through prophets, that is a divisive within Christianity, right? That is a divisive thought?
当你谈论上帝今天如何说话，并且你相信是通过先知时，这在基督教内部是有争议的，对吧？这是一个有争议的想法？
Very divisive.
非常有争议。
Why do you believe it?
你为什么相信它？
Because he's always had prophets. And it makes sense that just like he had profits in Old Testament times, he would continue with it. Why would he suddenly stop? I never quite understood why God would stop talking to his people.
因为他一直都有先知。这讲得通，就像他在旧约时代有先知一样，他会继续这样做。为什么他会突然停止？我从来没完全理解为什么上帝会停止与他的人民交谈。
Sure enough, Dad found someone he believes can commune directly with God.
果然，爸爸找到了一个他认为可以直接与上帝交流的人。
I am the great revealer.
我是伟大的揭示者。
Meet Julie Green, my dad's preferred prophet.
认识一下朱莉·格林（Julie Green），我爸爸最推崇的先知。
A great fall is coming, a fall of a global cabal. My children, 2024 will be a year like no other.
一场巨大的倒塌即将来临，一个全球阴谋集团的倒塌。我的孩子们，2024年将是不同寻常的一年。
I firmly believe that God did lead me to Julie Green.
我坚信上帝确实引领我找到了朱莉·格林。
She's not particularly big online, a couple 100,000 subscribers, but she's part of a growing movement within Christianity that emphasizes spiritual warfare and politics. It's all very Trumpy and full of prophecies.
她在网上不算特别有名，有几十万订阅者，但她是基督教内部一个强调精神战争和政治的运动的一部分。这完全是“特朗普式”的，充满了预言。
Secrets in the White House are about to be revealed. The Obamas, the Clintons, Adam Schiff, Mitch McConnell, Chuck Schumer, Nancy Pelosi--
白宫的秘密即将被揭露。奥巴马、克林顿、亚当·希夫、米奇·麦康奈尔、查克·舒默、南希·佩洛西——
As you can probably tell, this is where Dad's getting most of his predictions. And when I talk to Dad about these predictions, it's clear that for him, they all stem from his religious beliefs, which I've always found somewhat confusing because when I look at his list, none of these things seem to have anything to do with God at all.
正如你可能看出来的，这就是爸爸大部分预测的来源。当我与爸爸谈论这些预测时，很明显，对他来说，它们全都源于他的宗教信仰，而我一直觉得这有点令人困惑，因为当我看他的清单时，这些事情似乎与上帝毫无关系。
In July, some news-- President Biden announced he was withdrawing as the Democratic nominee for president. I thought, what was Dad's prediction again? Oh, he said, removed from office. Guess I'm in the clear.
在7月，有一些消息——拜登总统宣布他将退出民主党总统候选人提名。我想，爸爸的预测是什么来着？哦，他说，“被免职”。看来我是赢定了。
As the year sped by, I read books with titles like When Prophecy Fails. I spoke to a number of clinicians and conspiracy experts, met my dad's pastors. I even interviewed several of his friends. None of them shared his beliefs, but they said they didn't really argue with him about it either. Only one said it hurt their friendship with Dad.
随着这一年飞逝，我读了诸如《当预言失败时》之类的书。我与一些临床医生和阴谋论专家交谈，见过爸爸的牧师。我甚至采访了他的几个朋友。他们没有一个人认同他的信仰，但他们说他们也并没有真正就此与他争论。只有一个人说这伤害了他们与爸爸的友谊。
Sometimes I'd send Dad highlights of articles debunking some of his more out-there claims, like the one about how the Joe Biden you see on the news is actually a body double.
有时我会给爸爸发一些文章的精选，驳斥他那些更离谱的观点，比如关于你在新闻中看到的乔·拜登实际上是一个替身的那一个。
Well, it's actually a common practice in a lot of third world countries. Look at Saddam Hussein. Saddam Hussein had-- they aren't even sure, but over a half a dozen body doubles. That's why he could appear in one part of the country one day and someplace else another day.
嗯，这实际上在很多第三世界国家是一种普遍的做法。看看萨达姆·侯赛因。萨达姆·侯赛因有——他们甚至无法确定，但有超过半打的替身。这就是为什么他能一天出现在这个国家的某个地方，第二天出现在另一个地方。
Yeah, I don't think they were giving speeches and making policy on his behalf, though. You know what I'm saying?
是啊，但我不认为他们在代表他发表讲话并制定政策。你明白我的意思吗？
Some of them were.
其中一些是这么做的。
I think they were just maybe like--
我认为他们可能只是……
Some of them were.
其中一些是这么做的。
--a little quick appearance.
——偶尔露个面。
But mostly, yeah, they were just appearances. Fun fact, while we're talking about body doubles, when the Biden--
但主要是，是的，他们只是露面。有趣的事实是，当我们谈论替身时，当拜登——
Why do you call him "the Biden"?
为什么你叫他“那个拜登”？
Well, because it's a body double.
嗯，因为那是个替身。
[CHUCKLES] OK.
[笑] 好吧。
The last time Netanyahu, who's the Israeli prime minister, came to visit the US here in Washington, DC, it was interesting that the fake Biden stood 6 inches taller than Netanyahu. Netanyahu and Biden are both listed to be 5 feet, 10 inches tall. So don't you find it interesting that when they were standing side by side in a couple of photos, that Biden was suddenly 6 inches taller?
上次内塔尼亚胡，以色列总理，来美国华盛顿特区访问时，有趣的是那个“假拜登”比内塔尼亚胡高了6英寸。内塔尼亚胡和拜登的身高都标注为5英尺10英寸。所以你不觉得有趣吗，当他们在几张照片中并排站立时，拜登突然高了6英寸？
Well, first of all, Biden's listed height is 6 feet. Let's see what Netanyahu's height is. He's also 6 feet, it says.
嗯，首先，拜登的身高标注是6英尺。让我们看看内塔尼亚胡的身高。上面也说他是6英尺。
OK, yeah, they're the same height. The point is, they're the same height. I thought it was 5' 10". So yeah. So it's 6 feet.
好的，是的，他们身高一样。重点是，他们身高一样。我以为是5英尺10英寸。所以是的。所以是6英尺。
Are you talking about this image?
你说的是这张图吗？
Yeah, I think that's it. Yeah.
是的，我想是这张。是的。
He looks a little taller. Well, but he's taller in every picture. This is a different place.
他看起来确实高一点。嗯，但在每张照片里他都更高。这是个不同的地方。
Are they the same height?
他们身高一样吗？
They don't look the same height in this picture.
在这张照片里他们看起来身高不一样。
OK, that's my point. They are the same height.
好的，这就是我的观点。他们身高一样。
Well, people lie about their heights all the time, right? So I'm sure-- Allen Iverson was always listed as 6' 1". He was actually 5' 10", right? People--
嗯，人们总是对身高撒谎，对吧？所以我肯定——阿伦·艾弗森的身高一直被标为6英尺1英寸。实际上他是5英尺10英寸，对吧？人们——
I get that. I get that. But presidents don't do this.
我懂那个。我懂。但总统不会这样做。
My fact-checker wants me to point out here that we don't actually know Allen Iverson's real height, or Netanyahu's height, or whether or not Saddam Hussein had body doubles. But this is the joy of debating a conspiracy theorist. Inevitably, you run out of patience or just don't know the facts well enough to continue pushing back. So whenever I debate Dad, it feels like I can never do enough research or compile enough evidence.
我的事实核查员想让我指出，我们实际上不知道阿伦·艾弗森的真实身高，或者内塔尼亚胡的身高，或者萨达姆·侯赛因是否有替身。但这就是与阴谋论者辩论的乐趣所在。不可避免地，你会失去耐心，或者只是没有足够的知识储备来继续反驳。所以每当我辩论时，感觉就像我永远做不够研究，也搜集不够足够的证据。
Later in the summer, I was reading a science journal and saw a possible way around that. This research group was doing some experiments where they had some conspiracy theorists engage in conversations with AI chatbots, which had all the facts, could push back gently, and unlike me, had infinite patience. The data on its effectiveness looked pretty promising, so I reached out and actually got them to program something special just for my dad to try, which he did for several minutes.
夏天晚些时候，我在读一本科学杂志，看到了一个可能的解决办法。这个研究小组正在做一些实验，让阴谋论者与AI聊天机器人进行对话，这些机器人掌握所有事实，可以温和地反驳，而且与我不同，拥有无限的耐心。数据的有效性看起来非常有前景，所以我联系了他们，实际上让他们专门为我爸爸编程了一些特别的东西，他为此尝试了几分钟。
To be honest, it didn't say anything that I hadn't already heard.
老实说，它没说出任何我以前没听过的内容。
Swing and a miss. But the work continues.
打偏了。但工作仍在继续。
In August, Dad got it in his head that Kamala Harris was going to be replaced as the Democratic nominee at the convention. And out of nowhere, he made a second political conspiracy bet, this time with my mom. The terms-- if Mom lost, she'd have to give up, as he put it, all mainstream media for the rest of the year. And if he lost, he'd have to stop watching Julie Green entirely, his favorite prophet. Much to Mom and I's delight, he lost that bet a few days later when Harris officially accepted the nomination.
在8月，爸爸脑子里认定卡玛拉·哈里斯会在大会上被替换为民主党候选人。他莫名其妙地打了个第二个政治阴谋论赌，这次是跟我妈妈。条款——如果妈妈输了，她就必须放弃他所说的“所有主流媒体”直到年底。如果他输了，他就必须完全停止观看朱莉·格林的节目，那可是他最喜欢的先知。让妈妈和我高兴的是，几天后哈里斯正式接受了提名，他输掉了那个赌约。
Your father's in his silk robe, and he's got a cocktail.
你父亲穿着丝绸睡袍，拿着鸡尾酒。
Yeah, drink up, buddy.
是啊，喝吧，老兄。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So Dad, so no more Julie Green till the end of the year?
所以爸爸，那么直到年底都不看朱莉·格林了？
Correct.
没错。
How do you feel about that?
你对此感觉如何？
I'm disappointed, but it's OK. I have other resources.
我很失望，但没关系。我有其他资源。
It did feel like a relief that he wouldn't be watching Julie Green anymore. And him admitting he was wrong? That was something.
他不再看朱莉·格林的节目确实让我感到一种解脱。而且他承认自己错了？那还算是一回事。
By the fall, Dad and I were speaking more than ever and in ways we never have.
到了秋天，爸爸和我的交流比以往任何时候都多，方式也前所未有。
Do you feel like I know you now better?
你觉得你现在更了解我了吗？
Oh, absolutely. Yeah, you know me, these conversations and just talking about my dad and all the rest, absolutely.
哦，当然。是的，你了解我，这些谈话，还有聊到我爸爸以及所有其他事情，当然。
And of course, football season was kicking off, so there were lots of calls and voicemails about Ohio State.
当然，橄榄球赛季开始了，所以关于俄亥俄州立大学的电话和留言多了很多。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Three penalties on this drive against Ohio State, and now Johnson waiting back.
这次进攻中俄亥俄州立大学被罚了三次，现在约翰逊在后面等待。
They should have thrown on first down or at least second down. Anyway, I'll talk to you at halftime.
他们早该在第一次进攻就传球，或者至少在第二次尝试时。总之，中场休息时我再联系你。
Dad and I were getting along better than ever, but time on our bet was running out.
爸爸和我的关系比以往任何时候都好，但赌约的时间快到了。
We're down to the last four months, last third of the year.
我们只剩下最后四个月了，一年的最后三分之一。
How do you feel about that?
你对此感觉如何？
Um, impatient. I really thought more would have happened by now.
嗯，不耐烦。我真以为现在会发生更多的事情。
I don't think I ever asked you this, and I should have asked you-- why did you challenge me to this bet?
我想我从来没问过你这个，我本该问你的——你为什么要用这个赌约向我挑战？
Oh, why did I challenge you to this bet? That's a good question. I wanted to get your attention.
哦，为什么要用赌约挑战你？这是个好问题。我想引起你的注意。
Like, what do you mean by that?
比如，你这话是什么意思？
Well, because I wanted you to believe that God is still active and alive and still in control of the world. And I thought this would be a concrete way for you to see that and experience that.
嗯，因为我希望你相信上帝仍然活跃、仍然活着，并且仍然掌控着世界。我想这是一个具体的方式，让你去看到并体验到这一点。
Man, I didn't think about it that way. So it's sort of about you wanting me to get closer to God.
伙计，我没从那个角度想过。所以这算是关于你想让我更接近上帝。
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, I think that's very touching. I think you're super wrong about all these predictions, but that your reasoning is very touching.
我的意思是，我觉得这非常感人。我觉得你在所有这些预测上都大错特错，但你的动机非常感人。
OK.
好的。
I appreciate that. Anyways, OK. Let's end on a high note.
我很感激。总之，好的。让我们以积极的基调结束吧。
OK, sounds good. We'll talk to you soon.
好的，听起来不错。我们很快再聊。
Sounds good. Love you guys.
好的。爱你们。
Hey, and you know what, Zach?
嘿，你知道吗，扎克？
Huh?
嗯？
This alone has been well worth it. All the conversations--
光是这个就完全值得了。我们进行的所有这些谈话——
Oh.
哦。
--we've had, this alone, I mean, to be perfectly honest, if I had to pay you 50 grand for the time we've spent together, every penny has been worth it.
——光是这个，老实说，如果我要为你我们在一起的时间支付5万块，每一分钱都是值得的。
Dad, well, I can't handle you saying things like that. This is too nice. This is too sweet. It's too sweet. I appreciate it, Dad. It's actually been really nice talking to you, too.
爸爸，嗯，我没法应付你这么说。这太好了。太甜蜜了。太甜蜜了。我很感激，爸爸。其实和你谈话也很棒。
All right.
好了。
好的。
Take care.
保重。
You, too. Good night.
你也是。晚安。
As we stretch into November, Dad, Mom and I got hit with some sad news. After a year of nearly no contact with my father, my sister informed the family that she wouldn't be coming home for the holidays, which, in my lifetime, I count only three times we've ever missed the holidays together.
随着进入11月，爸爸、妈妈和我收到了一个悲伤的消息。在与我父亲几乎断绝联系一年后，我妹妹通知全家，她假期不会回家了，这在我有生之年，我记得我们一起错过假期的次数屈指可数。
Why aren't you coming home for Christmas?
为什么你不回家过圣诞节？
Because I don't want to be there. Oh. I feel like I'm going to cry. [SIGHS]
因为我不想在那里。哦。我觉得我要哭了。[叹气]
(EMOTIONALLY) I think last year was so terrible, incredibly terrible for me. And the thought of being back in that space feels awful. Why would I choose that? I'm not going to get OK with him believing that I'm somebody that I'm not and wanting so badly for me to be something else.
（情绪激动）我觉得去年太糟糕了，对我来说简直糟透了。一想到要回到那个空间就觉得可怕。我为什么要选那个？我没法接受他相信我是个我根本不是的人，并且那么强烈地希望我成为别的东西。
And it's hard because I say that, and then I immediately think, well, that's what I want from him. I want him to fundamentally change who he is and be a different person. That's where I feel stuck is, like, we want the same things from each other. And I don't know if that's possible.
这很难，因为我说了这些，然后我立刻想，嗯，那也是我想从他身上得到的。我想让他从根本上改变他是谁，变成另一个人。这就是我感到困境的地方，就像我们彼此想要同样的东西。我不知道这是否可能。
I don't know either. The bet was nearly over, but it felt like our family was barely hanging on. Then December came. It was just days before Christmas, days before I was flying home and Mom called me with another update.
我也不知道。赌约快结束了，但感觉我们的家庭已经摇摇欲坠。然后12月到了。距离圣诞节只有几天了，距离我飞回家还有几天，妈妈又给我打了个电话更新情况。
Hey, how are you?
嘿，你好吗？
A lot going on in the last 12 hours. [SIGHS]
过去12个小时发生了太多事。[叹气]
She began to fill me in. The night before, Mom and Dad were talking about the state of the family over dinner.
她开始给我填补细节。前一天晚上，妈妈和爸爸在晚餐时谈论家庭的状态。
And I told him that he was welcome to come Christmas Eve, but that, likely, Christmas Day, you and I would do something by ourselves. And he got very upset.
我告诉他他欢迎在平安夜过来，但很可能，圣诞节那天，你和我会在自己做点什么。他变得非常生气。
And we had a-- I mean, I can't remember exactly all the parts of the conversation, but I said, the reasoning, how I got to this place was the situation with Kira. And then I was tolerant of his religious journey. I can be tolerant of political differences. But when he started following the YouTube shit--
我们有过一次——我的意思是，我不记得谈话的具体所有部分，但我说，我之所以走到这一步的原因是基拉的情况。我对他的宗教之旅保持宽容。我可以宽容政治差异。但当他开始关注那些YouTube上的屎——
Prophet.
先知。
The prophet stuff and what I feel is fake news and all of the doom and gloom and generators and flats of water and granola bars all over the place, I said, I just-- I can't anymore. I just can't anymore. Our 40-year history is just not enough for me. We are already living very, very separate lives.
那些先知的东西，还有我认为是假新闻的一切，所有的末日论，以及随处可见的发电机、箱装水和燕麦棒，我说，我就是——我再也受不了了。我就是再也受不了了。我们40年的历史对我来说已经不够了。我们已经在过着非常、非常独立的生活。
Separate realities.
独立的现实。
Yeah, and separate realities. I didn't say that. He said that he's not going to change his religious viewpoints. He's not going to change. And then I just said it. And I just don't see a path where this marriage can continue. I don't see a path for me.
是啊，独立的现实。我没说那句话。他说他不会改变他的宗教观点。他不会改变。然后我脱口而出了。我实在看不出这段婚姻还能维持下去的路径。我看不到属于我的路径。
And what did he say?
他说了什么？
He sort of didn't really respond.
他没怎么回应。
After 40 years of marriage, they had agreed to separate and for my dad to move out. Dad's beliefs around Kira, the conspiracies, it had just become too much.
在结婚40年后，他们同意分开，爸爸搬出去住。爸爸关于基拉的信念，那些阴谋论，已经变得太沉重了。
I'm embarrassed to say the situation with Kira wasn't the one that knocked it over. But I was ever hopeful that he would come to a reality about that. But what I realized is that he's beyond redemption at this point.
我很尴尬地说，基拉的情况并不是压垮骆驼的最后一根稻草。但我曾经一直希望他能在那件事上回到现实。但我意识到，他现在已经无可救药了。
There's this little piece of me that is like, you have this conversation with him on January 1, his list is debunked. He will realize, if he steps back and looks at the whole picture, that he's not grounded in any reality, and that he'll have an awakening, and I will have a marriage and a family.
我内心有个小小的念头，如果他在1月1日与你对话，他的清单被驳斥了。如果他退后一步，审视全局，他会意识到自己没有立足于任何现实，他会有所觉醒，而我将拥有一个婚姻和一个家庭。
So this was the situation I flew home to. Things felt weird. I spent the week crashing at friends' houses and in hotels. Mom slept in Kira's room. Christmas Day, as you can imagine, was sad. There were no gifts exchanged. Mom and I just went to the movies and ate Chinese food. I'm not even sure what my father or sister got up to that day. A few days later, Dad said he was ready to sit down and close out the bet.
所以这就是我飞回家时的情况。事情感觉很怪。那周我住在朋友家和酒店里。妈妈睡在基拉的房间。圣诞节那天，你可以想象，很悲伤。没有互换礼物。妈妈和我只是去看电影，吃了中餐。我甚至不知道我父亲和妹妹那天做了什么。几天后，爸爸说他准备坐下来结束这个赌约。
Coming up, somebody's going to need to say, as promised, you were right, I was wrong, which can be such a powerful thing in any relationship. That's in a minute, Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，有人需要兑现承诺，说“你是对的，我错了”，这在任何关系中都是一种非常有力量的事情。稍后继续，芝加哥公共广播。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Our show today, 10 things I don't want to hate about you, about Zach Mack and his year-long bet with his dad. We've arrived at the end of December. Zach's family is not doing well. And there's still the bet.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目，关于“我不想恨你的10件事”，关于扎克·麦克和他与父亲为期一年的赌约。我们已经到了12月底。扎克的家庭状况不好。而且还有一个赌约。
I know this sounds crazy because as bad as things had gotten, Dad was still excited about settling up. I had no idea what he was going to say. But as we often are, we started off pretty playfully, which is our way of postponing the hard stuff.
我知道这听起来很疯狂，因为即使情况已经变糟，爸爸仍然很兴奋地想要了结赌约。我不知道他会说什么。但就像我们经常做的那样，我们开始得相当轻松，这是我们推迟面对困难事情的方式。
All right. OK, here we go.
好了。好的，我们开始吧。
All right. Hand me the wine here. Oh, I should go get my list, right?
好的。把酒递给我。哦，我应该去拿我的清单，对吧？
Yeah, go get your list.
是的，去拿你的清单。
Yeah, let me just have it, too, so I can look at it and see if there's anything I can pretend happened.
是的，也让我看看，这样我可以看着它，看看有没有什么我可以假装发生了的事情。
Well, at least so far, we're sharing a reality. OK, I'm just going to go through the list for your 10 predictions for the year. We'll start there.
嗯，至少到目前为止，我们还共享一个现实。好的，我打算过一遍你的10个年度预测清单。我们从那里开始。
OK.
好的。
We'll start with the easy ones. There's four that can easily be grouped together. And that is Barack Obama will be convicted of treason, Joe Biden will be convicted of treason, Nancy Pelosi convicted of treason, the Clintons convicted of treason and murder. Right? Those are all kind of-- I would group them categorically.
我们从简单的开始。有四条很容易归为一组。那就是：巴拉克·奥巴马将被判叛国罪，乔·拜登将被判叛国罪，南希·佩洛西被判叛国罪，克林顿夫妇被判叛国罪和谋杀罪。对吧？这些都是某种程度上的——我会把它们归为一类。
Right, yeah.
没错，是的。
I began-- no investigations, no charges, no convictions, literally no momentum of any kind.
我开始——没有调查，没有指控，没有定罪，字面上没有任何进展。
And yes, I fully hoped that would take place before the end of 2024, but that has not taken place.
是的，我完全希望在那在2024年底之前发生，但并没有发生。
If you're keeping score at home, that's four for me.
如果你在家里记分，那就是我得4分。
All right, next one. You said Trump will be reinstated without an election. Trump won reelection. He was not reinstated without an election. That's five. Next prediction, Trump will have all charges dropped. On May 30, 2024, Trump was found guilty and convicted on 34 felony charges in the New York hush money trial.
好了，下一条。你说特朗普将不经选举复职。特朗普赢得了连任。他并没有不经选举复职。那是第5分。下一个预测，特朗普将撤销所有指控。2024年5月30日，特朗普在纽约封口费案中被判34项重罪成立。
Yeah.
是的。
To be fair to Dad, charges in two other cases were dropped, but Dad's prediction was all charges, so that makes six for me.
对爸爸公平地说，其他两个案子的指控被撤销了，但爸爸的预测是所有指控，所以那是我得6分。
Moving on, next one, you said Governor Hochul, the governor of New York, would be removed from office. Governor Hochul is currently in office with no charges being brought against her. She will be up for reelection in 2026.
继续，下一条，你说州长霍楚尔，纽约州州长，将被免职。州长霍楚尔目前在职，没有对她提出任何指控。她将在2026年竞选连任。
That is correct.
那是正确的。
Seven. Onto the home stretch-- Biden will be removed from office.
第7分。进入最后冲刺——拜登将被免职。
So Biden's still in the White House. You're not rebutting that.
所以拜登还在白宫。你没有反驳这一点。
Yeah, well, because somebody pretending to be the Biden is in the White House.
是的，嗯，因为一个假扮成拜登的人在白宫里。
OK.
好的。
[CHUCKLING]
[笑]
And we're back to body doubles. But even still, he conceded the point, so that's eight. OK, then there's Eric Adams, the mayor of New York, who Dad predicted would be removed from office, which still might happen. But Dad said by the end of 2024.
我们又回到替身话题了。但即便如此，他承认了这一点，所以那是第8分。好的，然后是埃里克·亚当斯，纽约市长，爸爸预测他会被免职，这可能还会发生。但爸爸说是在2024年底之前。
As it stands right now, he's still the mayor.
目前的状况是，他仍然是市长。
Right.
没错。
Tough break, but that makes nine. OK, last one--
难受，但那是第9分。好的，最后一条——
Our country would come under martial law. As far as I know, that didn't happen.
我国将进入戒严状态。据我所知，那没发生。
That did not happen.
那确实没有发生。
OK. Any rebuttals there?
好的。有什么反驳意见吗？
I'm very happy that didn't happen.
我很高兴那没有发生。
And that makes 10.
那是10分。
However--
然而——
Oh, no.
哦，不。
--I still see that as a strong possibility of happening. I think it still has a strong possibility of happening within the next two months.
——我仍然认为那发生的可能性很大。我认为那在未来两个月内仍然有很大的发生可能性。
Here we go.
来了。
And I still am 100% positive that all these are true.
而且我仍然100%确定所有这些都是真的。
Even though none of them came true?
即使它们一个都没实现？
Even though none of them have been actualized by the end of 2024.
即使它们在2024年底之前都没有实现。
So your explanation for why these things did not yet come to pass is that you just got the timeline wrong?
所以你对这些事情还没实现的原因的解释是，你只是时间轴弄错了？
Yes.
是的。
We're sort of starting where we're ending, which is you still believe what you believe, and I still believe that that's false.
我们算是回到了原点，也就是你仍然相信你所相信的，而我仍然认为那是假的。
Correct.
正确。
I had waited for so long to hear him say the magic words we agreed to a year ago. Now the moment finally came.
我等了太久才听到他承诺说出那一年前我们约定的魔力词汇。现在时刻终于到了。
Wow, Zach, I was wrong. And, um-- and what?
哇，扎克，我错了。而且，嗯——而且什么？
And not only were you wrong--
而且不仅是你错了——
Oh, and you were correct.
哦，而且你是对的。
To tell you the truth, hearing this was completely unsatisfying because I knew he didn't really believe it. I had won the bet, but it didn't really feel like winning.
说实话，听到这个完全无法让我满意，因为我知道他并不真正相信这一点。我赢了赌约，但感觉一点都不像赢了。
I just see an unwillingness for you to be wrong.
我只是看到你不愿意承认自己错了。
Wrong about 10 things. I'm going to admit, I was wrong about the timeline on all 10 things. I've been wrong--
错了10件事。我会承认，我在所有10件事的时间轴上都错了。我已经错了——
But you see how you prefaced it?
但你看到了你是怎么开头的吗？
I've been--
我已经——
Not that you're wrong about them. You're just wrong about the timeline.
不是说你在这些事情上错了。你只是在时间轴上错了。
Yeah. But that's still a type of wrong.
是的。但那仍然是一种错误。
Sure, but it's a half measure. It's a way for you to be right.
当然，但这只是半吊子的妥协。这是你保持正确的一种方式。
I can't say I was surprised. All year long, I had read about how unlikely it is to pull someone away from these kinds of beliefs, how when believers of a prophecy witness it not come to pass, that oftentimes, they inexplicably double down, which was exactly what he was doing.
我不能说我很惊讶。整整一年，我都在阅读关于把人从这类信念中拉出来有多么不可能，关于当预言的信仰者见证预言没有实现时，他们往往会不可思议地加倍坚信，这正是他正在做的。
All of these beliefs, it feels like you're really holding on to them. And I'm not sure why.
所有这些信念，感觉你真的紧抓着它们不放。我不确定为什么。
Because I know they're true. Why am I going to abandon truth? Why would I believe a lie? Why would I give that up? And it's not an arrogant thing. It's a knowing in my soul and in my spirit. So yeah, I mean, I can't abandon the truth.
因为我知道它们是真的。我为什么要放弃真理？我为什么要相信谎言？我为什么要放弃那个？这不是傲慢。这是我灵魂深处的认知。所以是的，我的意思是，我无法放弃真理。
I was getting nowhere, and it was frustrating. But I thought, this is history repeating itself. Surely, he could see that, right?
我一筹莫展，这令人沮丧。但我想，这是历史在重演。他肯定能看出来，对吧？
One of the things I've thought a lot about during this process is your dad and what happened to him. And in the face of so many people around him, including yourself, saying, "Hey, you're going down the wrong road. Don't do this. Please listen," and he wouldn't. He wouldn't hear it from anyone. And it cost him his life. I see a lot of parallels with what's happening right now.
在这个过程中我思考了很多的一件事是你父亲和他身上发生的事。在周围那么多人，包括你自己，都在说：“嘿，你走错了路。别这样。请听听我们的劝告，”但他就是不听。他不听任何人的话。那让他付出了生命的代价。我看到了现在发生的事情有许多相似之处。
Interesting.
有趣。
I don't think you're at risk of physical danger so much.
我不认为你面临身体危险。
Yeah.
是的。
I think you're at risk of a lot of other things.
我认为你面临许多其他危险。
Like what?
比如什么？
[SIGHS] Financial ruin. I think you're at risk of being ostracized and completely left out of this family dynamic.
[叹气] 经济破产。我认为你面临被排斥和彻底排除在这个家庭动态之外的风险。
That would break my heart. But I see that.
那会让我心碎。但我看到了。
I think you're at risk reputationally.
我认为你在名誉上也有风险。
How so?
怎么说？
I feel like the closest friends in your life, your family, the people around you are telling you, hey, you're going the wrong way, and you're not listening.
我觉得你生命中最亲近的朋友、你的家人、你身边的人都在告诉你，嘿，你走错了方向，而你不听。
Actually, none of them are saying that to me.
事实上，他们没一个人那么跟我说。
None of them?
一个都没有？
None of them.
没有。
OK.
好的。
The only people who've said that are you and Mom.
只有你和妈妈那么说过。
So if all those people told you, would you hear them?
所以如果那些人都告诉你，你会听吗？
I would listen to them. I probably wouldn't change, but I'd listen to them. I'd take it into consideration.
我会听他们的。我可能不会改变，但我会听。我会把它纳入考虑。
[SIGHS]
[叹气]
So.
所以。
You don't think that sounds like your dad?
你不觉得这听起来很像你爸爸吗？
That aspect of it, yeah. But my dad, my dad had trouble living in reality. I don't have trouble living in reality.
那个方面，是的。但我爸爸，我爸爸在现实中生活有困难。我没有在现实中生活的问题。
I would argue that you do. I mean, look at the state of our family right now. And I think we've gotten to this place in large part because of your beliefs.
我会反驳说你确实有。我的意思是，看看我们家庭现在的状态。我认为我们走到这一步在很大程度上是因为你的信仰。
Well, we've gotten here completely because of a difference in beliefs. Yeah, you can point the finger at me and say, it's because of your beliefs. Well, that's partially true, but it's simultaneously because of the three of your beliefs, right?
嗯，我们完全是因为信仰差异才走到这一步的。是的，你可以指着我说，是因为我的信仰。嗯，那部分是真的，但同时也是你们三个人的信仰导致的，对吧？
And I understand your beliefs, but I don't believe that way. I'm not going to pretend I believe that way. And I know you guys don't want me just to pretend. You want me to embrace it and live it and think it and breathe it, the same way you do. I can't do that.
我理解你们的信仰，但我并不那样认为。我不会假装我那样认为。我知道你们也不想让我仅仅是假装。你们想让我拥抱它、生活在其中、思考它、呼吸它，就像你们一样。我做不到。
[SIGHS]
[叹气]
Therefore, it creates a wedge, right?
所以，它制造了一个隔阂，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
But it doesn't have to. I think the post-COVID years have really magnified and polarized people.
但不必如此。我认为疫情后的几年真正放大和两极化了人们。
Yeah. But I would say that's when you got radicalized. I don't think, ultimately, Mom, Kira, and I have changed a lot ideologically since that time. I don't think you're in the same place.
是的。但我会说那时你被激进化了。我不认为，最终，妈妈、基拉和我自那时起在意识形态上改变了很多。我不认为你在同样的位置。
I can agree with that. I see that. I have made more significant changes in the past four years in terms of my own spiritual awareness and spiritual growth.
我同意这一点。我看到了。我在过去四年里在个人的精神觉悟和精神成长方面确实做出了更重大的改变。
[SIGHS] Yeah.
[叹气] 是啊。
So and that certainly, I know, feels and looks very radical.
所以，我知道那确实感觉起来看起来非常激进。
Let's talk about Mom for a second.
让我们谈谈妈妈。
Oh, I think your mom-- I don't know what I think about her anymore. [CHUCKLES] I mean, I don't think negative about her, other than she's lost and confused.
哦，我觉得你妈妈——我不知道我现在怎么想她了。[笑] 我的意思是，我不觉得她有什么负面影响，除了她迷茫和困惑。
I mean, I guess she would say that about you.
我的意思是，我想她会那样评价你。
Probably, and a lot worse. I continue to love your mom, but this is the irony. She sits in judgment of me and therefore judges me unworthy of being her partner and husband anymore. I mean, short of pretending to be somebody who I'm not, I don't see a solution.
大概会，甚至更糟。我继续爱着你妈妈，但这正是讽刺所在。她坐在审判席上评判我，因此认为我不配再做她的伴侣和丈夫。我的意思是，除了假装成一个我不是的人之外，我看不出有任何解决方案。
Yeah. I agree.
是的。我同意。
I watched his frustration rise as he came up empty over and over, slowly realizing there was no fixing this.
我看着他的挫败感不断上升，因为他一次次落空，慢慢意识到这件事根本无法修复。
I mean, look, I think this year has been difficult, especially recently. I do feel like we are getting along really well. I do feel conflicted because as that's happening, you and Mom are getting separated, and Kira is not home for Christmas. And those are all because of your beliefs.
我的意思是，看，我觉得这一年很困难，尤其是最近。我确实觉得我们相处得很好。我确实感到矛盾，因为当这种情况发生时，你和妈妈在分居，而基拉没回家过圣诞节。这些都是因为你的信仰。
I can accept you and love you and have my beliefs and accept your beliefs. You can't accept my beliefs without judging me.
我可以接受你并爱你，同时拥有我的信仰，并接受你的信仰。你无法在不评判我的情况下接受我的信仰。
You don't think you're judging Kira?
你不觉得你在评判基拉吗？
Not at all. I love my daughter. I love Kira.
完全没有。我爱我的女儿。我爱基拉。
I know that you do.
我知道你爱她。
I would never, I would never disown my daughter.
我永远、永远不会跟我的女儿断绝关系。
But I think Kira does feel rejected. She does not feel fully accepted by you.
但我认为基拉确实感到被拒绝了。她确实没感到被你完全接受。
Yeah, I get that. It's not about rejection. See, that's how you guys label it. But it's not rejection. It's about looking at it from a spiritual viewpoint where this is not what God wants for her.
是啊，我明白。那不是拒绝。你看，那就是你们标记它的方式。但那不是拒绝。那是在从精神观点看待它，因为这不是上帝对她想要的。
As the conversation wound down, I let go of any notion that I could convince him of anything. I was finally ready to stop struggling and just accept the truth. I couldn't help him.
谈话接近尾声时，我放弃了任何我可以劝服他的念头。我终于准备好停止挣扎，只是接受现实了。我帮不了他。
I just want to say, I do really appreciate-- ooh, man, sorry. [SNIFFLES, SIGHS] It's been-- it's been a hard year, man. Yeah. I mean, I appreciate the conversations we've had all year. Like, I do feel-- I don't know. I feel closer to you than I ever have. And I'm really sad about the state of this family.
我只是想说，我确实真的很感激——哦，天哪，抱歉。[抽泣，叹气] 这是——这是艰难的一年，伙计。是的。我的意思是，我感激我们全年进行的谈话。真的，我感觉——我不知道。我感觉和你比以往任何时候都更亲近。我对这个家庭的状态感到非常难过。
Yeah.
是的。
But I do appreciate your openness, your willingness to-- [CRYING] you never ducked. You never ducked a hard question.
但我感激你的坦诚，你愿意——[哭泣] 你从不退缩。你从不逃避困难的问题。
No need to.
没必要。
[SNIFFLES, SIGHS]
[抽泣，叹气]
I don't know. I mean-- [SNIFFLES] where do you think we'll be next Christmas?
我不知道。我的意思是——[抽泣] 你觉得明年圣诞节我们在哪？
I-- [LAUGHS] I don't know. I have no idea. I have no idea, man. [SIGHS] I can't even think that far ahead.
我——[笑] 我不知道。我完全不知道。我完全不知道，老兄。[叹气] 我甚至没法想那么远。
Yeah. Yeah, I have one final question for you.
是的。是的，我有一个最后的问题要问你。
OK. [CHUCKLES]
好的。[笑]
How are you going to pay me? [CHUCKLES]
你要怎么付我钱？[笑]
Um--
嗯——
Check? Should we go to the bank? Should I get one of those giant golf checks? [LAUGHS]
支票吗？我们去银行吗？我要去弄那种巨大的高尔夫球支票吗？[笑]
I figured you'd probably want small, unmarked bills.
我猜你可能想要小额、无标记的钞票。
Yeah.
是的。
Nonsequential.
非连号的。
Yes.
是的。
So did you bring a suitcase?
那你带行李箱了吗？
Yeah, I have a gym bag.
带了，我有个健身包。
OK. We'll fill that puppy up.
好的。我们把那个小家伙装满。
Let's do it.
干吧。
We made the bet a year ago, but I've waited a lot longer than that to have this conversation with him.
我们在一年多前打的赌，但我等了比那长久得多的时间才和他进行了这次对话。
[SIGHS] All right. Let's get a hug.
[叹气] 好了。来个拥抱。
(CHUCKLING) All right. Oh, I love you.
（笑着）好了。哦，我爱你。
I love you, too.
我也爱你。
As we stood there hugging, I just broke down.
当我们站在那里拥抱时，我崩溃了。
I'm sorry. I'm sorry it's been-- [CRYING]
对不起。很抱歉这一年——[哭泣]
I don't know what comes next, where the family goes from here. It felt like things fell apart so quickly, but also slowly over many years. I think in many ways, I'm the one who got off the easiest. I'm still in good standing with everyone, which makes me feel a mixture of relief and guilt. And if you're wondering, yes, I took the money. Absolutely.
我不知道接下来会发生什么，家庭会走向何方。感觉一切分崩离析得太快，但也历经多年缓慢地发生着。我想在许多方面，我是那个走得最容易的人。我仍然和每个人保持良好关系，这让我感到一种解脱和愧疚的混合情绪。如果你想知道，是的，我拿了钱。绝对拿了。
OK. Now we're walking to the Rose Bowl.
好的。现在我们走去玫瑰碗球场。
Yeah.
是的。
How do you feel?
你感觉如何？
But on New Year's Day, the day my dad officially lost the bet--
但在新年那天，也就是我爸爸正式输掉赌约的那天——
I'm pumped up.
我兴奋极了。
--I took him to go see Ohio State, our favorite football team, play in the Rose Bowl--
——我带他去看我们最喜欢的橄榄球队——俄亥俄州立大学，在玫瑰碗球场比赛——
What do you think the score is going to be?
你觉得比分会是多少？
--and paid for everything.
——而且我付了所有费用。
I think it's going to be 31 to 22, Bucks.
我觉得比分会是31比22，“七叶树”赢。
Yet another prediction my father got wrong, by the way. But they did win. Go, Buckeyes.
顺便说一下，这是我父亲预言错误的又一件事。但他们确实赢了。加油，“七叶树”队。
Let's go! All right! Let's go!
加油！好了！加油！
It felt good to treat dad with his own money and to agree on the one reality we've always shared-- football-- maybe the only one we ever will. As I watched the clock run down, I knew that the moment the game was over, we'd have to face the fact that, as a family, in the end, we didn't make it.
用我爸自己的钱款待他，并对我们一直共享的唯一现实——橄榄球——达成共识，这感觉不错，也许这是我们唯一能共享的现实了。看着时间流逝，我知道比赛结束的那一刻，我们必须面对一个事实：作为一个家庭，最终，我们没能挺过去。
Zach Mack. He's a producer at Vox Media. His story was a collaboration with NPR's Embedded podcast, which, if you haven't heard them, you should check them out. They have lots of documentary stories like this. David Kestenbaum, on our staff, worked on the story here. The staff who worked on it there were producers Dan Girma and Ariana Gharib Lee.
扎克·麦克。他是Vox Media的制作人。他的故事是与NPR的《Embedded》播客合作完成的，如果你还没听过，你应该去听听。他们有很多这样的纪录片式故事。我们工作人员大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆参与了这里的故事。那里的制作人员包括制作人丹·吉尔马和阿丽亚娜·加里布·李。
Editing by Luis Trelles. Katie Simon is Embedded's showrunner. Some original music in this episode was composed by Peter Leonard. Fact-checking by Gretta Pittenger on the Embedded staff and Christopher Swetala on our staff.
编辑是路易斯·特雷耶斯。凯蒂·西蒙是《Embedded》的节目总监。本集中的一些原创音乐由彼得·伦纳德创作。事实核查由《Embedded》工作人员格蕾塔·皮滕格和我们工作人员克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉负责。
NPR's Embedded is releasing a three-part series about Zach's bet with his dad that gets into material that we did not have time for here, including some revealing conversations with his dad's friends and some more interesting stuff from Zach and his dad. It is available now. You can find Embedded wherever you get your podcasts.
NPR的《Embedded》正在发布一个关于扎克和他爸爸赌约的三集系列，其中涉及我们这里没时间讨论的内容，包括与他爸爸朋友的一些揭秘性对话，以及扎克和他爸爸之间更多有趣的事情。现已上线。你可以在任何获取播客的地方找到《Embedded》。
Well, today's episode was produced by Lilly Sullivan. The people who put together today's show include Phia Bennin, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Angela Gervasi, Cassie Howley, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Frances Swanson, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Avery Trufelman.
嗯，今天这集是由莉莉·沙利文制作的。制作今天节目的人员包括菲亚·本宁、迈克尔·科米特、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德、安吉拉·格瓦西、卡西·豪利、查纳·乔夫-沃尔特、塞思·林德、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森、纳迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、阿丽莎·希普、弗朗西丝·斯旺森和黛安·吴。我们的执行主编是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。今天特别感谢艾弗里·特鲁费尔曼。
If you like our show and you want more of our show, we've been cranking out bonus episodes every two weeks. This week, the bonus episode is interviews with my cousin, the composer Philip Glass, including one where he sits at a piano and he explains what he hears when he listens to his own music.
如果你喜欢我们的节目，并想要更多，我们每两周都在加紧制作额外节目。本周的额外节目是对我堂兄，作曲家菲利普·格拉斯的采访，包括一个他坐在钢琴旁，解释他听自己音乐时听到了什么的片段。
To get that and all of our bonus episodes-- we've been trying all kinds of stuff-- become a Life Partner. When you do, you also get ad-free listening. You get the special archive of over hundred greatest hits episodes that show up right in your podcast feed for your convenience. How do you get all this? It could not be easier. Go to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners.
要获取那个以及我们所有的额外节目——我们一直在尝试各种各样的事情——请成为“生活伴侣”（Life Partner）。当你这么做时，你还可以获得无广告收听。你可以在播客订阅中方便地获取包括一百多个最热门剧集在内的特别档案。如何获得这一切？非常简单。前往 thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our show's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. Fun fact about him-- he has never seen a panda. He told me he's going to a zoo this weekend to do just that.
《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）分发给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。关于他的一个有趣事实——他从来没见过熊猫。他告诉我他这个周末要去动物园看看。
I think it will be very black and white.
我认为这将是非常黑白分明的。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着《美国生活》的更多故事回来。